[music playing]
No one has seen her.
If she's still alive,
she has vanished.
MAN 1: Here is the
treaty giving you
all the lands that constitute
the ancient kingdom
of East Anglia.
These lands I grant you
in perpetuity, to settle
and to farm as you see fit.
MAN 2: Look, Bjorn.
Look at this treasure.
That is not the end
of our business today.
Guards, arrest the traitors.
[shouting]
[grunting]
No, no, I'm innocent.
MAN 1: He saved my life.
He was implicated.
You have--
I've already decided
to forgive him.
If you won't talk
to him, please give
me your permission to do so.
I need to know why, so
perhaps I can forgive him.
MAN 3: Is this a god?
No God.
That is the Buddha.
Who is the Buddha?
[laughter]
MAN 4: It seems to me that
you are conflicted, Peter.
There's no
contradiction because it's
possible that everything
is part of the one.
You know, I've often
wondered whether you
weren't a little crazy.
I'm crazy?
Just like Margrethe.
You know what happened to her.
MAGGIE: What was that?
WOMAN 1: Maggie.
MAN 5: Why did you travel
all this way in such weather?
Everyone is dying.
There is so little food
and everyone is sick.
I know we don't deserve
to be saved, but please,
Floki, go and save my family.
My father has learned a lesson.
He has changed.
They killed your son and
they killed your daughter.
I'm going to leave the
decision to you, Kjetill.
If Helgi says his father has
changed, then I believe him.
MAN 6: Why do you
want to see me?
Lord Cyneheard
confessed everything.
It's true.
They wanted to stage a coup
just before we left for battle.
They wanted me to
give the signal.
I refused.
Then you are involved.
I will never, ever
betray him again.
Stand aside!
Out of the way!
[horse whinnying]
My lady, it's the king.
WOMAN 2: Go and
fetch the physicians.
MAN 7: What is wrong with him?
No one really knows.
Then he is weak.
We need to know the truth.
We cannot afford a sick king.
Alfred has suffered
these attacks before
and has always survived.
You must have faith.
Aethelred is very popular.
Yes.
What is it you say to these men?
I say to them what
I have a mind to say.
Don't interfere, mother.
I don't belong here.
I want to take Kattegat
back from Ivar.
You have no army.
MAN 8: But King Harald has.
Brother.
We shall attack
Kattegat altogether.
I have just received
some very interesting news.
It seems King Harald
was defeated in Wessex
by the new King Alfred.
It seems to me
that now it is time
for us to return to England.
Harald has learned his lesson.
He cannot win without me.
I don't believe you have ever
accepted your brother as king.
I don't think you ever would.
What have you done?
WOMAN 3: You would always
be a danger to him.
So you've poisoned me?
What kind of mother are you?
[grunts]
[dramatic music]